bonsoir françois mitterrand est
optimiste il croit aux chances d'un
accord sur le gâteau bernard tapie est
soulagé son élection de député en mars
dernier n'a pas été invalidé par le
conseil constitutionnel
muriel bolle n'a pas craqué la
belle-soeur de bernard laroche a résisté
à toutes les confrontations gênante pour
elle lady diana et malheureuse elle
trouve les médias étouffant elle veut
apparaître de moins en moins souvent
pablo escobar ne tuera plus le parrain
de la drogue a été tué par les policiers
à medellin en colombie
sa mort mettra-t-elle fin au trafic
international de drogue et aux violences
qui l'accompagnent je poserai la
question notre invité alain labrousse
directeur de l'observatoire géopolitique
des drogues bonsoir mais revenons
auparavant avec patrice romedenne sur
l'élimination physique du roi de la
cocaïne pour avoir passé le coup de fil
de trop pablo escobar achève sa carrière
sur une civière le corps criblé de
balles
avant-hier le jour de ses 44 ans il
téléphone à son épouse et à ses deux
enfants tous trois séjournent dans un
hôtel de bogota après avoir été refoulé
d'allemagne
mais quand il décroche le combiné
escobar ignore que quelque part dans
medellin
une camionnette truche et de matériel
électronique reconnaît sa voix et
localise l'appel
le lendemain 500 policiers et soldats
boucle le quartier escobar apparaît sur
le toit de cette maison qui lui sert de
planque sur les forces de l'ordre ils
vident un puis deux chargeurs et tombe
un pistolet dans chaque main mais si les
tireurs d'élite ont tué ce qu'au bar les
politique que prône la vigilance
pablo escobar est mort mais le trafic de
drogue continue c'est évident la lutte
contre les narcotrafiquants et les
terroristes est une lutte internationale
une heure après l'action commando la
mère et la soeur d'escobar connaissent
le corps simultanément une partie de la
population rend hommage à celui qui
inspirait
et respect pablo
ils scandent le prénom d'un assassin en
qui il voit un bienfaiteur parce qu'il
offrait des logements sociaux avec de
l'argent sale et ce sont les mêmes que
l'on retrouve aujourd'hui pour veiller
le corps en présence de la mère qui crie
sa douleur et de la soeur qui menace une
liste des gens que vous les journalistes
devriez interroger sur les attentats les
assassinats et les massacres dans les
quartiers populaires monsieur cocaïne
avaient grossi il s'était laissé pousser
la barbe artifices d'un homme en fuite
qui depuis 16 mois vivait dans la
clandestinité
ce soir les forces de sécurité
colombienne kadri la ville de medellin
dans la crainte d'une vague d'attentats
cela peut surprendre pablo escobar était
aimé des siens les plus pauvres tout
simplement parce qu'il les aide mais
avec l'argent de la drogue avec l'argent
de la mort beaucoup d'argent il avait à
une époque fournit 80% de la cocaïne
dans le monde
michèle fines négociations et cette
interview inédite de pablo escobar temps
lui même le roi de la cocaïne l'avait
fait parvenir en 88 à la justice
française afin de s'expliquer quelques
mois plus tôt sur l'île de marie galante
dans les antilles les policiers de la
lutte anti drogue avait réalisé une
saisie record 4 186 kg de cocaïne
l'enquète leur avait permis de remonter
jusqu'au chef du cartel de medellin en
octobre 90 pablo escobar été condamné en
france par défaut à 20 ans de prison
maintenant je pense qu'il faille del
mundo et sabrina colocation innopole
arrestation elles ont ajouté des
occasions et l'egypte rhinoise au
problème des répressions pablo escobar
aimé qu'on le compare à robin des bois
dans les quartiers pauvres de medellin
il avait fait construire une cité de 500
logements pour les plus démunis
mais pablo escobar avait une hantise
celle d'être extradé aux états unis où
ils avaient été plusieurs fois condamné
aussi lorsque le nouveau président de
colombie césar gaviria avait décidé la
non extradition des trafiquants qui
acceptaient de se livrer pablo escobar
avait pris le pari le 19 juin 91
il faisait son entrée à une vie gado une
prison spéciale dont il avait lui même
dessiné les plans elle allait devenir le
qg du cartel de medellin
lorsque les autorités colombiennes
avaient voulu le faire déménager un an
plus tard pablo escobar s'était enfui
depuis il était en cavale
sa tête était mise à prix pour 40
millions de francs un parent est mort un
autre sur gilberto rodriguez orejuela
dirige le cartel de cali plus efficace
dit tant que jury de medellin parce que
plus discret maryse burgot on l'appelle
le joueur d'échec parce qu'on le dit
très intelligent fin stratège
c'est une des rares photos que nous
ayons de lui car c'est avec discrétion
que rodriguez orejuela dirige avec son
frère le cartel de cali cali repères
d'une centaines de narcotrafiquants
encore plus efficaces que ceux de
medellin ils font de l'argent avec les
feuilles de coca mais il fréquente la
bonne société de cali cela ne tue pas il
achète ce qui pourra les déranger il ya
une différence entre ceux de cali et
ceux de medellin
le cartel de medellin a comme une erreur
capitale
ils ont commencé à tuer des
personnalités politiques à poser des
bombes entre le gouvernement ceux de
cali n'ont jamais déclaré la guerre au
gouvernement il se contente de faire des
affaires
aujourd'hui le cartel de cali fourni
plus de 70% de la drogue qui arrive aux
états unis et en europe
en fait qu'ali a depuis longtemps
supplanter medellin est ici l'argent de
la drogue est savamment réinvestis ce
membre du cartel propriétaire d'un
laboratoire nous explique que les narcos
ce de cali sont avant tout des
financiers ils demandent des conseils de
grands économistes et à des industriels
est comme ça ils montrent un même des
industries on peut dire aujourd'hui
qu'ici à cali 80% des grandes industries
dépendent de l'argent de la drogue
depuis quelques temps le cartel de cali
développe la culture du pavot et donc la
production d'opium et d'héroïne un
marché aujourd'hui beaucoup plus
rentable que celui de la coca ces images
sont extraites d'un documentaire qui
sera diffusé en février sur france 2 et
qui a été réalisé par mylène sauloy et
gilles de maistre à la brousse je vous
ai présenté tout à l'heure au début de
ce journal vous êtes directeur de
l'observatoire géopolitique des drogues
est ce que la mort d'escobar change
quelque chose
si une mort symbolique c'est un grand
criminel qui a été tuée et ça pourrait
renforcer le moral de ceux qui luttent
contre la brande mais dans la pratique
depuis plusieurs années escobar n'était
plus directement dans le trafic de
cocaïne d'abord parce que il assuré les
transports ensuite il l'a exercé un
racket sur c est ce qu associer sous le
prétexte qu'il avait ouvert des routes
et que dorénavant il était plus facile
de percevoir de l'argent en les faisant
payer pour cette initiative donc ce
qu'on dit du cartel de cali donc les
successeurs est vrai
oui tout à fait et cela fait d'ailleurs
longtemps que le cartel de cali a
commencé son ascension s'est écroulé
mois oui et c'est surtout depuis que
escobar a déclaré la guerre à l'état
colombien que les kills est consacré à
des activités militaires à laisser de
côté un peu ses activités de trafiquants
que le cartel de cali à petit à petit
occuper ses parts de marché donc c'est
ça qui est terrifiant quoi qu'on fasse
ça repousse si j'ose dire comme le
chiendent
oui et non dans le cas du cartel de cali
sont avancés ne serait pas possible s'il
ne jouissait pas de complicité dans
l'appareil d'état il ya eu un procès par
exemple où la dea est venu apporter des
éléments justifiant la demande
d'extradition et orihuela a été absous
donc aucune avis aucun avis de recherche
ne pèsent sur lui en colombie il est
seulement réclamé par les états unis et
d'autres pays étrangers
donc il peut en toute tranquillité agir
en colombie alors vous avez dit appareil
d'état en joue parfois candides on croit
que l'état fréquences sont des individus
un petit peu isolé des gangsters
alors que parfois il ya des pays
trafiquants avec tout à fait et dans le
cas de la colombie
on peut dire que si escobar a pu
résister aussi longtemps c'est qu'il
était sans arrêt averti par de hauts
membres de la police de la justice des
forces armées des poursuites contre lui
et ceux qui l'ont acculé c'est en fait
un groupe terroriste clandestins qui
groupait des anciens associés qui
voulait se venger de lui les gens du
cartel de cali qui finançait et et des
policiers qui opérait en dehors de leur
travail ne parle de la colombie ça
paraît loin mais s'il ya un produit qui
traverse comme ça les frontières c'est
bien la drogue avec son cortège de
d'attentats ou de mort et la france que
se passe-t-il en france est ce que le
trafic ces temps où diminue d'abord la
fpt la drogue qui causent tous les
problèmes en france c'est l'héroïne est
l'héroïne n'est pas la cocaïne et
l'héroïne essentiellement dans les
banlieues chez les marginaux chez les
gens n'ont intégré et cette héroïne
vient essentiellement du croissant d'or
par la route des balkans c'est à dire du
pakistan de l'afghanistan et elle
redescend travers l'iran la turquie les
pays de l'est etc
donc c est là aussi on s'aperçoit que
des pays comme le pakistan sous l'ancien
gouvernement doit donner un sursis à
benazir butto mais le gouvernement qui
l'a précédé connaissait des ministres
qui étaient des barons notoire une
partie des services secrets de l'armée
est investi dans le trafic de drogue et
un pays comme la france devait faire
davantage posé davantage de conditions à
son aide économique aux investissements
qu'elle peut faire dans ce pays où vente
d'arbres
on le sait mais on ne le dit pas s'il
est tout à fait étonnant que les médias
parlent aussi peu du pakistan qui est
nôtre notre colombie la colombie c'est
le problème des états unis
essentiellement à travers le crack qui
est une drogue assez destructrice et qui
est très répandue aux états unis qui a à
peine commencé chez nous ne l'entend
avancer et on pourrait avoir les moyens
d'y mettre fin mais lui c'est un
problème très difficile parce que le mal
est déjà très avancé il faudrait une
véritable volonté politique des grands
états or on s'aperçoit que dès qu'il ya
des contradictions entre les intérêts
économiques et géostratégiques des
grandes nations
que ce soit les etats-unis la france ou
n'importe quel pays importants et bien
la drogue et rapidement oubliée au
profit de ses intérêts merci alain
labrousse si les propos dans la brousse
nous ont intéressés vous pouvez acheter
le livre qui vient d'être publié aux
éditions le seuil avec alain wallon la
planète des drogues merci bonsoir jean
marie villemin a supplié aujourd'hui
muriel bolle de dire la vérité sur la
mort de son fils grégory muriel bolle a
dit sa vérité bernard laroche n'a pas
tué grégory dominique verdeilhan gilles
dobler chaque matin et ce depuis six
semaines jean marie villemin a tant que
muriel dise la vérité sur la mort de son
enfant
aussi aujourd'hui c'est lui qui passe à
l'offensive cherchant à son tour à
déstabiliser le témoin tu as deux
enfants dont l'un à 4 ans l'âge qu'avait
grégory aujourd'hui grégory devrait
avoir 13 ans il faut que plus tard tu
puisse regarder tes enfants en face si
tu peux vivre avec un secret aussi
monstrueux je te plains muriel ne se
démonte pas je n'ai pas de secret c'est
quand même toi qui a assassiné bernard
et bernard il est innocent pour la
quatrième fois depuis le début du procès
jean michel lambert fait face à la cour
d'assises
il est évident que muriel n'a pas été
maltraités physiquement et moralement
elle a subi une pression psychologique
délicat le juge lambert ajoute elle
avait 15 ans et elle n'est pas non plus
une intellectuelle
cette pression muriel bolle la subit de
nouveau depuis quatre jours sans que
personne ne réussisse à trouver la
faille
pour jean marie villemin muriel bolle
s'est enferré dans un
ange et la partie civile n'a qu'un seul
appui à l'issue de cette sixième semaine
de procès jean michel lambert est une
fois de plus le petit juge semble être
un homme bien seul une bonne nouvelle
enfin pour bernard tapie le député des
bouches du rhône craignait d'être
invalidée par le conseil constitutionnel
pour dépassement des dépenses autorisées
lors de sa campagne électorale il ne l'a
pas été bruno roger petit c'était en
1992 au lendemain des élections
régionales hervé fabre aubrespy rpr été
reçus sur le yacht de bernard tapie
cela avait fait beaucoup jaser à
marseille par la suite les deux hommes
s'étaient affrontés aux dernières
législatives et ses tapis qui avait
gagné depuis son adversaire de droite
n'en démordrai pas le vainqueur avait
selon lui dépensé beaucoup d'argent trop
d'argent aux yeux de la loi
mais aujourd'hui bernard tapie est
désormais tranquille le conseil
constitutionnel a jugé que le député des
bouches du rhône n'avait pas dépassé le
plafond législatif
une bonne nouvelle pour l'intéressé
alors c'est important parce que c'est la
plus haute juridiction et que dans ces
conditions là on s'aperçoive beaucoup
non seulement des soupçons mais surtout
des pronostics sombres sont souvent sans
fondement et malveillant bernard tapie
sorti d'affaires sur ce dossier va
devoir maintenant faire face aux députés
lors du débat relatif à l'éventuelle
levée de son immunité parlementaire
tapie seul contre tous il s'y prépare
déjà ne pas s'attendre à une plaidoirie
tapie estime que la tribune de
l'assemblée vaut mieux que cela il
devrait plutôt évoquer la france et lui
un vrai discours de politique générale
parce que ça comme il le dit souvent
parlant de lui il sait faire mais revers
tapie a droit à la une cette semaine du
nouvel économiste qui pour mieux le
connaître à interroger tous ceux qui ont
croisé son chemin ses amis comme ses
ennemis ils se sont vus en tête-à-tête
ils se sont parlé ils sont restés un
sampan une d'or une heure c'est énorme
le tout paris politique et ait bahi
il dit qu'il s'agit d'un événement c'est
donc un événement
roland sicard ivb avons patienté sur le
perron de l'élysée en attendant l'issue
de la rencontre entre françois
mitterrand et michel rocard
dès le premier abord on sentait que
l'événement était important les motards
étaient là prêts à bondir pas de doute
l'elysée avait mis les petits plats dans
les grands en fait
renseignements pris tout cela n'était
pas pour michel rocard c'était pour
françois mitterrand lui-même avant son
départ pour la suisse mais tout de même
pour le nouveau premier secrétaire du ps
l'événement est de taille
son dernier tête-à-tête avec françois
mitterrand c'était il y a plus de 200
d'ailleurs à la sortie c'était la
pagaille des grands jours et si rocard
n'était pas très bavard il était content
tout simplement bien dans quelle
ambiance
on n'en saura pas plus les grands
bonheurs sont souvent discrets la
reprise des relations diplomatiques
entre l'elysée et le pc pourtant un
signe rocard a bel et bien terminé sa
reconquête du parti socialiste
mais une autre rencontre et reste à
faire plus difficile celle de l'opinion
bernard stasi veut retrouver des bulles
dans son champagne le maire d'epernay
veut reconquérir son siège de député
perdu en mars dernier à notre grande
surprise la validation de son adversaire
lui permet de se représenter
elle n'a voulu cette fois rien négligé
et a demandé à jacques chirac de
l'accompagner donc de le soutenir
bernard stasi est centriste reportage de
jean baptiste près dali et maryse les
chats il y a des moments où il est bien
utile d'avoir un ami connu bernard stasi
et jacques chirac ont fait l'ena
ensemble et pour retrouver sa
circonscription perdue en mars dernier
bernard stasi a bien besoin de tous les
concours etc à epernay une partie du rpr
soutient son adversaire et dissidents
pro chirac mais anti nazi
du coup hier soir pour aider un ami
centriste est de 30 ans tous les
arguments étaient bons si d'aventuré ce
qui dans vivre à part stasi était battu
eh bien je ne vous dirais certainement
pas merci parce que là encore aucun
observateur ne manquera de remarquer que
je viens peu de crédit pour bernard
stasi l'élection c'est plutôt une
affaire de crédit à reconquérir sur le
terrain il reconnaît l'avoir négligée en
mars dernier
trop sûr d'un siège occupé 25 ans et
d'une certaine conception de la
politique
finalement vous savez les électeurs les
trompent pas comme cela
ils savent bien qu'il faut télé à paris
pour défendre les intérêts de la
circonscription qu'il faut aller dans
les ministères pour se battre et ça je
ne continuerais le faire et c'est ma
façon d'être proche des préoccupations
des électeurs est la proximité c'est
l'argument de campagne préférée de
philippe martin et lure marc vernet avec
49 points d'avant vigneron nouveau venu
en politique mais issu de la droite
locale depuis six mois pour le contacter
il n'a pas lésiné
et pour les arguments il a une cible une
cible unique
bernard stasi sur l'absentéisme et son
immobilisme face aux dossiers importants
en fait qu il a chuté en mars
c'est plutôt l'homme de la politique
politicienne alors que moi je suis
plutôt l'homme de terrain nous sommes
totalement différent cinq autres
candidats sont en lice de la gauche au
front national dans les plaines
d'epernay d'immenses il y aura du
champagne mais pas pour tout le monde
les obsèques de claude labbé ont eu lieu
aujourd'hui de très nombreuses
personnalités du mouvement gaulliste se
sont rendus à l'église sainte clotilde à
paris
parmi elles le premier ministre edouard
balladur et le président du rpr jacques
chirac claude la bt l'ancien président
du groupe gaulliste à l'assemblée
nationale il était aussi député des
hauts-de-seine
françois mitterrand est relativement
optimiste il croit aux chances d'un
accord sur le gat le chef de l'état l'a
confié à l'occasion de sa visite en
suisse
c'est vrai que une amorce de compromis
était proposée est suffisant ma réaction
personnelle
au moment où je vous parle et faute
d'avoir pu suivre les chose d'aussi près
puisque je suis parmi vous c'est que
c'est le bon chemin mais il faut aller
plus loin un compromis ça veut dire que
personne n'a tout à fait raison
n'obtient tout à fait raison
si l'on adopte des positions
maximalistes on est sur des choux et tel
n'est pas l'intention de la france qui
désire l'accord mais ne peux pas
l'accepter au détriment de ses intérêts
les plus évidents c'est ce dont on va
discuter maintenant
et l'on apprend ce soir qu'un projet
d'accord complet du gatt sera soumis
lundi aux ministres des affaires
étrangères des 12 une réunion a eu lieu
cet après midi à matignon
notre approbation dit-on à matignon ne
vaut que pour la date mais là aussi à
matignon comme ministère français des
affaires étrangères on se montre
relativement optimiste
en suisse le président la république
s'est rendu compte que les agriculteurs
français n'étaient pas les seuls à
grogner contre le gâte les suisses aussi
pour des raisons que nos envoyés
spéciaux
jean yves perrin et michel jeannot latos
nous rapporte le gat ça gratte aussi les
paysans suisses
jacques et marc zeller le père et le
fils n'ont pas l'habitude de ce plat se
considère même comme des paysans plutôt
aisée il exploite 65 hectares en suisse
la moyenne tourne autour de 15
ils ont un quota de production de 250
mille litres de lait seul l aurait payé
un peu plus d'un franc suisse par litre
4 france français à prix élevés fixés
par le gouvernement fédéral pour
maintenir le maximum d'agriculteurs sur
leurs exploitations et les consommateurs
suisses acceptent de payer cher pour
cette même raison
leurs principaux produits alimentaires
pour les paysans suisses l'accès aux
marchés prévues par le gap
c'est le début de la concurrence et donc
la fin de ce système chute des prix donc
illuminer sion du revenu changement de
mode de vie
augmentation des heures de travail passe
probablement diminution de la main
d'oeuvre diminution du confort des
animaux comme que constatent ils sont
très à l'aise et très calme mais qu'on
fera moins attention à ce qu'on fait on
foncera dans le tas procédé sur rue
c'est une ingérence dans les politiques
intérieures des pays pour que les
américains puissent livrer chez nous
leur surproduction et ça nous ne pouvons
l'accepter
du coup les agriculteurs suisses
regardent du côté de l'union européenne
suit avec passion les dernières
négociations entre washington et
bruxelles espère même que les français
se fasse tentant en aidant le bas avec
tout le monde on est heureux que les
françaises bat posséde sauvé il part de
marché de l'agriculture parce que si si
les français arrivent à obtenir quelque
chose
la suisse en profitera aussi malgré le
froid la neige et le brouillard ils
seront des milliers de mains devant le
siège du gatt à genève ils y
retrouveront d'autres paysans venus de
france d'europe et même d'amérique du
nord
1963 1993 un anniversaire a été célébré
il prend une valeur de symbole au moment
où la relation entre la france et
l'allemagne tentent quelque peu le 30e
anniversaire du traité de l'elysée qui
avait marqué précisément le
rapprochement spectaculaire entre les
deux pays
rapprochement voulu par de gaulle et
adenauer et évoqué aujourd'hui adresse
puis aux invalides par françois léotard
et son homologue allemand reportage de
françois punch les et georges en scène
vestiges du communisme à dresde dans
l'ancienne rda dresde rasée par les
bombardiers anglais ont février 45 150 à
300 mille morts dresde reconstruite par
les communistes qui avaient jusqu'à la
réunification fermer le musée à la
gloire de la wehrmacht
ce matin les ministres français et
allemand de la défense
ils ont inauguré une exposition pour le
30e anniversaire du traité franco
allemand signé par de gaulle et adenauer
l'esprit du traité de l'elysée le
charles de gaulle et konrad adenauer
promouvoir c'est un esprit de paix il
faut que les jeunes générations
apprennent ce qu'on est et nos conflits
et à quoi nous avons voulu mettre fin la
brigade franco-allemande embryons du
corps européen de défense est le symbole
de cette volonté
ce général allemand et ce soldat
français sont convaincus qu'en apprenant
à vivre ensemble on désapprend la guerre
je ne suis adressée en français
à ce jeu nomade il a répondu en allemand
c'est l'esprit de la brigade franco
allemande
et si un jour il devait y avoir un
problème entre la france et l'allemagne
je pense que tous ceux qui sont passés
par la brigade franco allemande sera
incapable de lever larmes contre les
autres et cette journée franco allemande
s'est terminée aux invalides à paris où
les deux ministres ont inauguré une
exposition semblable au musée de l'armée
française une exposition n'est jamais
qu'une exposition
mais l'héritage perdure renault et volvo
ont divorcé mais français suez devant du
mal à réaliser
il est vrai qu'ils vivaient ensemble
depuis quatre ans difficile dans ces
conditions de ne plus revoir pascal
golomer c'est lui qui a fait chuter son
président lui qui a donné le coup de
grâce à la fusion avec renault
aujourd'hui le directeur général de
volvo présente ses excuses à la france
mais j'espère dit il que la coopération
avec renault pourra malgré peu se
poursuit cette alliance
voilà près de quatre ans qu'elle a
commencé raymond lévy avait alors signé
l'accord pour renault les capitaux des
deux groupes sont croisés la coopération
industrielle touche déjà plusieurs
secteurs dans le design la recherche
les achats de pièces l'informatique il y
à des directions communes et les modèles
futurs devait être développé en sang
alors que faire si matignon considère
toujours officiellement que la fusion
reste une bonne solution
chez renault on tire un trait définitif
sur le projet et l'on veut examiner
l'alliance actuelle au cas par cas ou
regarderont ce qui peut être fait et ce
qui ne peut pas être fait je le redis ce
là où l'élément de confiance absolue
l'idée d'un avenir commun est essentiel
franchement aujourd'hui ça me paraît
difficile
faut il rechercher d'autres partenaires
en europe les rumeurs de discussions
avec fiat pourrait de nouveau faire
surface
mais l'italienne à la santé fragile
paraît bien moins séduisante aujourd'hui
que l'ancien fiancé suédoises un
accident nucléaire s'est produit à
cadarache dans les bouches du rhône 10
kilos de combustible ont fondu par la
faute des hommes plutôt par la volonté
des hommes ils ont fait exprès pour voir
patrick esther à l'intérieur de ce
véritable blockhaus situé dans le
sud-est de la france et pour la première
fois au monde dans l'histoire de l'atome
civil
les ingénieurs avaient décidé de tester
l'accident le plus grave pouvant
survenir dans une centrale atomique dans
un réacteur de type piscine
il s'agissait de faire fondre à 2800
degré 10 kilos de combustible nucléaire
l'essai a eu lieu hier
14h30 une lueur bleue va irradier le
réacteur sous l'effet de la radio
activité intense voilà c'est fini
le coeur vient de fondre il libère des
gaz de la vapeur d'eau et des produits
de fission extrêmement radioactif dans
les circuits de la centrale nucléaire
reconstitué en miniature pour l'occasion
les écrans s'affole 300 capteurs à
limone des batteries de calculateurs qui
enregistre des dizaines de milliers de
mesures
il s'agit de savoir quelle quantité de
radioactivité a été libérée par
l'accident
et surtout comment circule ces éléments
dans l'installation
le but bien sûr c'est de prévoir quel
serait le danger pour l'environnement
en cas d'accident grave dans une
centrale de l'edf
cette expérience était nécessaire
également pour savoir si l'on pouvait
oui ou non se fier au calcul effectué
habituellement sur ordinateur il faudra
au minimum six mois pour analyser les
enregistrements mais on peut déjà
affirmer que l'accident provoqué n'a pas
dégénéré en véritable catastrophe
une erreur a été commise tout à l'heure
dans le reportage à epernay de jean
baptiste prédalles une erreur
d'incrustation au philippe martin
l'adversaire de bernard stasi dans cette
élection législative qui aura lieu
dimanche le premier tour et divers
droite et bernard stasi est le candidat
de l'udf et du rpr en tout cas le
candidat soutenu par les deux
partie cette ratification est importante
pour qu'il n'y ait pas de recours à deux
jours du premier tour de l'élection
législative la princesse diana est
malheureuse non pas parce qu'elle est
princesse mais parce qu'elle est trop
connu trop exposé vous ne la verrez plus
sur papier glacé
enfin moins souvent question marigot nos
interventions très émouvante de la
princesse diana
cet après midi à londres face à la très
forte pression des médias depuis
quelques mois elle a annoncé
solennellement ses nouvelles intentions
vestiaire à la fin de cette année quand
j'aurai accompli mes engagements
officiels jeu réduire l'importance les
activités publiques que j'avais
jusqu'ici une princesse au bord des
larmes et très applaudie david haye
s'est rendu compte que les médias
s'intéressait beaucoup trop sa vie
privée dernière preuve celle du journal
mirror qui a publié il ya un mois des
photos prises à son insu dans un club de
gymnastique
elle souhaite se consacrer davantage à
ses deux garçons william et harry
sa première priorité at elle précisé en
réalité depuis quelques semaines le
prince charles héritier de la couronne
ne cachait pas son irritation
depuis leur séparation il ya un an seule
la princesse avait les faveurs de la
presse alors que ses propres activités
royales étaient réduites mais ces
derniers mois le fils aîné de la reine
est multiplié les sorties publiques et
la même souhaité avoir plus de travail
la princesse tire sa révérence le prince
peut reprendre le premier rôle la
réconciliation n'est pas au programme ni
leur divorce strelow vis ils appellent
déjà l'affairé elle a subjugué comme
elle a fasciné tous les amateurs de
danse stries l'officier a été choqué
quand je lui rapporter une expression
d'un confrère qui voient en elle le
maradona du ballet ils nous demandent de
ne pas confondre le ballon le chausson
daniel lefebvre a filmé le show son
petit déjeuner au sommet entre
alessandra ferry et zizi jeanmaire
au menu les secrets du régime ben ali
alessandra fairisme dans ce choix yesil
on est très très grande mince c'est
qu'elle elle même elle lé lan un
tempérament prend parti quelle est la
super technique
enfin la dégoûte ne suffisant pas elle
al'oreille le chat
répétition avant le spectacle lagrasse
d'aller sandra ferry des jalles
la danse est une discipline mais c'est
une recherche et pour moi elles
recherchent quelque chose qui en anglais
dans c'est une façon de s'exprimer de
parler de notre âme de nous parler de me
trouver des niches chercher
un des moments clés le pas de deux
expressions du romantisme de l'homme
vous avez lu je le répète vous pourrez
l'admirer au palais des congrès jusqu'au
12 décembre
pour conclure je vais donner une bonne
nouvelle à nos amis du téléthon qui
s'apprête à tenir l'antenne pendant 30
heures non-stop
claude sérillon et gérard holtz eux ces
gens le berre qui me l'a communiqué
financier ont déjà recueilli âge
aujourd'hui à la bourse et au tour de la
bourse
780 mille francs de promesses de dons
soit déjà c'est pas mal pour un début
allez ça vous savez très bien c'est même
très bien je vais bien je parraine tels
que vous voyez je suis une loge
magnifique et je parraine avec bien sûr
c'est vous qui allez venez quand même
toute l'émission c'est vous les
spécialistes moi je bénis je parraine je
surveille je vous tiens je vous tiens
réveiller pour quelles raisons avez vous
souhaité le faire michel sardou parrain
du téléthon 93 pour quelles raisons
c'est pas une raison particulière on m'a
proposé d'y participer j'ai j'ai pensé
que je ne pouvais pas dire non ça me
paraît difficile de refuser de faire une
soirée comme celle-là c'est au profit
d'une recherche au profit d' d'un espoir
pour beaucoup de gens et puis c'est une
soirée que j'ai regardé souvent j'ai
beaucoup apprécié je tire mon chapeau
aux deux spécialistes parce qu'ils font
ça merveilleusement bien et à france 2
qu il le fait régulièrement depuis
depuis sept ans merci michel on demande
à nos deux marathoniens de lui dire
comment ça va se passer je commence 30
heures comme d'habitude le même système
évidemment que les autres années c'est à
dire qu'on promet de donner à la hausse
avec eux on le dit chaque année mais
l'année dernière c'est encore été plus
formidable 309 millions avaient été
promis en 92 et 310 millions sont
rentrés dans les caisses pour les
chercheurs et pour les enfants malades
c'est à dire que les français ont donné
plus qu'ils avaient promis ce qui est
absolument génial et cette année surtout
pendant les 30 heures on va vous
expliquer ce qui s'est passé au point de
vue génétique nous sommes sans doute à
l'aube d'une véritable révolution
médicale il ya eu des vaccins il ya eu
des antibiotiques
le professeur jean dausset qui a été
prix nobel a expliqué qu'on était sans
doute là ô allah a l'air d'une f1 au
début d'une ère nouvelle
une véritable révolution génétique avec
les progrès qui ont été faits ces
dernières années et je crois que tout à
l'heure paul on y aura un véritable
émotion parmi nous dans toute la salle
de l'agora d'evry ville nouvelle car
effectivement on va pouvoir utiliser
pour la première fois le mot de guérir
le mot de guérison et donc les promesses
de dons passer des promesses de guérison
je rappelle d'ailleurs que depuis 19h10
vous pouvez faire le 36 37 36 15 codes
téléthon on se retrouve donc dans
quelques minutes
le mot de la fin c'est pour le parent
qui vraiment être là ou pas pour me
surveiller pour nous soutenir je crois
pendant 30 heures les durs parce que
surveiller c'est le trac d'emphase
polmar je suis très très il eut donc je
serai au 20 heures donc j'avais le trac
cédées soutenaient ben j'espère que
cette soirée sera ce qu'on espère parce
que c'est vrai que c'est une nouvelle
ère qui s'ouvre c'est peut-être un
véritable espoir et c'est important pour
nous tous vraiment merci michel sardou
merci claude et gérard et bon courage
on va vous retrouver tout à l'heure avec
émotion avec chancel pivot ruggeri
christian morin et avec tous les
animateurs et journalistes de france2
france3 radio france et rfo ce soir
cette nuit demain matin et demain soir
dans quelques instants nathalie rihouet
vous annoncera du vent au nord-ouest du
soleil au sud est de la grisaille
ailleurs ensuite valérie maurice fera le
point sur la circulation écoutez bien
c'est le point routes de france 2 tous
les soins bonne soirée sur france 2 je
vous retrouve demain à 13 heures
bonsoir